oui et si lui par une paire de patins
l'étiquette indique 225 dollars les à la
caisse on lui demande plutôt 250 dollars
on lui montre deuxième étiquette qu'il
n'avait pas vu sur les patins contraire
y est sûre de ses droits louise ekland
deux shows un pour lui laisse les pattes
et au prix le plus bas 225 dollars 2
qu'on lui accorde en plus un rabais de
10 $ en vertu de la politique québécoise
d'exactitude des prix louis at il raison
oui pour sa première réclamation selon
la loi si deux pays différents sont
étiquetés sur le même article c'est le
prix le plus bas qui prévaut pour sa
2ème réclamations 10 $ de rabais c'est
non pour que louis et droit se dit
dollars il aurait fallu qu'il achète ses
patins dans une grande surface fully tri
sont seulement afficher sur les
tablettes or dans ce magasin d'articles
de sport il y avait une étiquette sur
chaque paire de patins remous de
l'histoire fait respecter ses droits
c'est bien connaître la loi ses yeux